what what does Al what do you want to do
now in your life I mean what what are
your goals though what are your new
goals for this year easy Katie Kirk
these questions are coming in out what's
your what is it what's my goal um I'm
writing a couple movies good um just I
want to do more stuff that's um that's
just in my control which is why I did um
you know that Dr Phil billur Show at The
Comedy Store uh it was awesome it was it
was all I like creating stuff from the
ground up and having uh you know a game
plan but having a lot just you know
leaving up to spontaneity and and impr
just playing I love using the stage for
more than just stand up and uh having
Burr jump in on that and and have it be
so fun and he was so game to do it I
mean you should definitely do one with
me it'd be so fun never never been asked
oh I asked you check your text messages
um I'll show you the text okay yeah um
Adam Divine and Andre are going to do
the next one great guys great uh but we
you know would love to have some
nonwhites so if you want to yeah I'd
love to do it just ask me you know um
you have fun you're so good at being off
the cuff and and and I feel like it's
one of those things that bur even said
he goes this was a little he didn't say
out of my comfort zone but he was like
it was just he said yes so quickly
because he was like yeah I'm always
doing stand up how long does that take
you to get get in that Dr Phil Jen aspo
from NV did it you know and that's he's
the best yeah about four hours Jen ASP
the best yeah you pay to do it oh yeah
yeah so more stuff like that and then I
mean ultimately I want my own show
whether it's sketch or not but I feel
like um what I'm doing with some of
these character things is uh is just
flexing another I don't muscle that I
have that I that I don't want to it's
like just because Mad TV did one and
done on CW doesn't mean I can't do
characters you know what I'm saying I
don't know two same thing like if you
it's like you don't get a certain part
or you don't do whatever that you're
supposed to just stop doing it or you
write one script and you try to get it
made and you know you get it a little
bit up the line and then it doesn't
happen and then you're like it's so easy
to go all right well I tried you know
it's like I don't know just got to keep
[__] now have you met Dr Phil no well
you can talk to Kirk I'm trying to make
it happen really he's good friends with
them yeah I talked to him about it I'm a
little nervous I want to meet him just
for the sake of letting him know that
it's all goof it's not like I'm not uh I
don't respect the guy or or you know
it's all out of it's all parody I'm not
trying to actually be uh offensive yeah
you're a talented guy man whatever you
do I know what do you think I should do
what do you see what do you see uh I
mean if I was your agent I would just be
like you know you're a good-looking guy
you're a funny guy I would try let's get
keep the auditions going you you've got
now some real legitimate movies under
your belt right and let's pursue that
and then also say late night oh wow talk
show really talk show wow told me that
yeah that's good Crush that I would love
that man for you yeah you hate that huh
no I I mean
no yeah you don't like but I know I mean
a variety show I think yeah and that's I
think what you would get out of that
right like I don't know it I watch found
sometimes and be like oh yeah that looks
really fun or even Kimmel and doing bit
but then I'm like man having somebody on
that you're not interested in feels like
a real challenge it's not and I'm um and
or maybe you go the other way and you
just kind of treat it as that and you
don't do I've
never in my life yeah have ever seen a
late night monologue or anything that
anyone's done that you've loved not just
loved it maybe Letterman Letterman
letter maybe Letterman oh Conan but
there's never never really I love I've
never laughed at them I've laughed at
guests yeah I've laughed at maybe some
bits they set up right that were just
you know inherently funny that anyone
could do them but um they're just to me
it it always it puts a cringe down my
spine yeah I'll watch I'll be at airport
I'll be at late night watching something
and I'll go
wait am I have I lost my [__] mind in
what realm is this [__] funny yeah
yeah I'm sorry I I'm supportive of
everyone and I and also I want I want to
say this I've seen Fallon at clubs make
me laugh right I have right it's just
the because of the medium it's just it
and people laugh at it yeah it's insane
yeah I'm sorry no did I go lose my mind
no are you in agreement with me or not
well you're right the audiences are like
primed up to it's just like when you see
like when you when you first saw Sasha
Baron Cohen and do Ali G you you as soon
as you see you go that's funny yeah
Nathan for you that's funny or even like
Wendy
Williams